I love re-watching this scene so much
it's very hardcore you practice the
darkest waterfalls in the background
yeah where around Salem aren't there
just like these mini Niagara Falls in a
pond they're magic waterfalls
yes
I did not break the DH
it's good I love that they'll break it
out for the shows
yeah this is a good excuse
is that my fault
so good it's not my mom it shows me
I just read the words I mean that's
that's how I feel about some comic books
I've read yeah that's you know I didn't
break they just bent the mind power it's
called out welcome back to new rock
stars will 2023 be Marvel's year of
Memphis Stone no no no no finally the
year of our Dark Lord with Sasha baronco
and rumored to appear as Mephisto both
in Iron hearts and an act of the
Covenant of Chaos in 2023 it truly does
look like the year
to be justified to point at our screens
and scream
that is Mephisto and this is inside
Marvel it's new Rockstar's weekly Marvel
reaction show it's our final episode of
the Year Mt and Jessica are out for the
holidays but I delayed my break so then
go in my honeymoon for the first two
weeks of January meaning right now
holding down the fort new rock stars
with Brandon Barrick that's right and
I'm happy to be here Eric I am ready for
Mephisto my dark lord to enter the MCU
and take it over and bring it to its
rightful place in the darkest of regions
of our souls I'm ready for him to just
reveal himself because I think he's been
here since the beginning he's just right
out of frame of the camera he's just
like on the other side of it just like
Agatha harknesses sitting at director's
chair and winking at Obsession us uh hey
Brandon I think I realized this may be
the first time or one of the first times
you and I have like shared one of these
before there might have been something
it could be I think this is my first
inside Marvel I think we did a big queue
before but this is my first inside
Marvel I believe I believe so oh my god
well this is very exciting then oh and
what an episode to be on our big I feel
like for the past three years we've made
this big prediction at the end of the
previous year to say this is the year
when mephistos arrived right but I feel
like 2023 is the year of my Fisto okay
it's Gotta happen well Eric that is the
big question okay will Mephisto finally
arrived in the MCU in 2023. hey
hell yeah back in October back in
October even a deadline reported that
Sasha Baron Cohen was going to be in the
ironheart series playing Mephisto the
Demonic Overlord in this case to the
hood played by Anthony Ramos in the
comics the hood actually gets his powers
from dormammu but dormamma was already
shown as an abstract Arc to mention
purple face voiced by Benedict
Cumberbatch in the 2016 Doctor Strange
movie so it makes sense that Marvel
might swap in a different demon from the
hood also Brandon you and I were both at
d23 we saw that ironheart panel and I
think do you remember Anthony Ramos
didn't he seem to be dancing around
something yeah he kept nervously
glancing over again absolutely this man
has performed on stage in live in front
of people hundreds of times in one of
the most in the biggest show in decades
okay and I've never seen someone more
nervous to be on stage with Kevin feige
staying right there he wanted to say it
he wanted to say something big because
he knows the people wanted it and he was
afraid you're right Eric he was so
afraid of saying the wrong thing he was
definitely Towing that line absolutely
and we all looked at each other's you me
and Tommy were like this is Iron Heart
what are they hiding for ironheart it
was a very awkward sequence and like we
could see the teleprompters and there
was nothing on the teleprompter for
feige he goes off the dome right he
doesn't read no teleprompter okay and
and Ramos you're scared because he was
afraid of saying the wrong thing
absolutely well then last week there's
one of these scoopers this one named my
time to shine hello reported this Sasha
Baron Cohen Mephisto news like it was
new like it was breaking news he's like
I got a scoop news two month old news
and then what was horrifying is I then
suddenly got a bunch of tags from
accounts who only now consider to be
legit news just pretty worrisome how
many folks on social media don't at all
listen to or follow actual legitimate
news sources but when some scooper with
a very mixed track record farts out
something on Twitter it's suddenly Front
Page News to them did you see this did
he see this I'm like yeah of course I
saw it two months ago yeah this this
story has been very weird because much
like the um uh uh the Harrison Ford you
know coming to the MCU it was like a
leak first a rumor and then it kind of
got confirmed right away the Sasha Baron
Cohen one has kind of been slow played
like deadline is covering it but they're
still being very like sources say
they're not really like confirming
anything yet uh but it does seem like
the story is stuck around long enough
and not been refuted I think it's got to
be true I mean it I don't know why they
would let it go for so long if it wasn't
a true story and that's the thing A lot
of people are like well deadline didn't
name any actual sources but it's like
it's different when it's deadline
Hollywood Reporter variety Entertainment
Weekly slate like all these different
actual these are journalistic
Enterprises that are verified that were
verified before verification was cast
into doubt in general but like they they
have a history of people who have close
relationships with the people who work
at these Studios and production
companies when they say sources say it
actually means something it's not some
Anonymous Twitter account who's like
follow my patreon for updates like no
this is real news it's real is a
deadline reports it I'm sorry uh it
needs something Eric's mad as hell and
he's not gonna take it anymore
I just want everyone to know the moment
Mephisto was confirmed and not say it's
confirmed some time later it's an
important sacred moment in history but
hey this same scooper claimed that Sasha
Baron Cohen actually spent a few days in
La shooting scenes with Catherine Hahn
for coven of chaos Mephisto and Covenant
of chaos Mephisto in this sequel to One
Division and that it's still slated to
release in late 2023 now no legit news
source has confirmed this why don't you
back it up with a source my sources that
I made it the [ __ ] up but there has been
other reporting from across the industry
that Broadway Legend Patti LuPone has
been casting Covenant of chaos that's
some other member of the coven this
story is in Patti LuPone I can't believe
it I mean
from the great white way as far as I
know she's she's done for now she's
taking a little she's done this before
but she's kind of dumb for now right
she's stepping away and this is like the
first thing she's gonna to do I wonder
what Drew her to it I wonder why she's
so into it and I mean she must be
singing right she's got to have a song
you got to give Patty a song she must oh
hopefully hopefully I mean it was
Catherine Hahn herself who did the
vocals for Agatha all along maybe I mean
that was the best needle drop in the MCU
as far as I'm concerned and maybe Patti
LuPone heard that and she's like I could
do that
you do better I mean give us a
background on Patti LuPone what is she
known from specifically in Broadway
you're a Broadway nerd I know you know
she's she's been in lots of shows over
the year uh she she does a lot of
Sondheim right she loves San she was in
a Revival of company at some point doing
the famous ladies who lunch song Here's
to the lady yes lunch and doesn't she
look over at Elaine Stritch who who's in
the original cast correct correct and
then and just kind of like does anyone
still wear
and cut to Elaine stretch and she's like
she's great with her head on uh she was
also in of course a Revival of Sweeney
Todd uh that was while uh uh well
regarded uh she was also uh famously
famously supposed to have a role in uh
Sunset Boulevard uh that eventually
Glenn Close snuck in and stole the roll
away from her it was a long a long
battle uh she sued
um Andrew Lloyd Webber about it and
famously loves to remark that uh because
she never actually started the show she
was guaranteed to be in the show and
never actually did it or did it for a
small like a couple days and then like
was done got replaced by getting close I
forget all the details of story but she
loves to say that Andrew paid for her
pool uh that she put her backyard after
she she got her money from that show
didn't Patty LuPone just go viral
recently for yelling at someone in the
audience who was on their phone or
something like that so there was there's
like this you know there's obviously
people have their phones out during show
and it's a big deal and things have gone
viral where actors have like called out
people during the show a lot of times to
people's excitement to Thrills because
we all hate it when someone's
interrupting uh the show now the problem
is
um there are accessibility issues for
people out there and some people use a
device that provides closed captioning
for a Broadway show or like you know
takes the audio and turns it into
something they can read and so the I I
heard that it may have been someone
using one of those and so her anger
could have been misplaced I don't know
we gotta work out the details folks you
know everyone should be able to enjoy a
night at the theater but if you're
playing Candy Crush you deserve to get
yelled at but if you're just trying to
understand the words
we all got to do better that's all we're
all trying to do better we're trying to
do better I think so also like I would
love to get yelled at by Patti LuPone
what a story what a New York I mean I
know I know you can take that everywhere
in life like oh my God usually when
casting news comes out like this it
means that a series is in production
because the way this news makes it to
the trades is you know by things like
call sheets going out you know call
sheets they have to be distributed to a
ton of people in production you look at
the names in the call shooting like oh
this is news I didn't know this person
would send also sag after paperwork
contract paperwork has to be sent to
several different offices around
Hollywood I used to work on a talk show
and like it's impossible to keep these
things a secret because so many
different people are involved and it
just gets really hard to keep things uh
Under Wraps at that point so usually
once stuff gets legit once the paperwork
is filed right and some people in
departments who don't care about leaking
this information because they're in the
accounting department they're like who
cares that someone knows uh Patti
lupone's on this show we care we all
care well we care we care well and we've
seen two lately right when like when
accidentally you know someone updates
you know a makeup artist or a customer
updates their resume uh just because
they're trying to get more work and then
they say they worked on a certain show
and dress a certain person and Suddenly
It's News and that poor person is
probably in on Kevin feige's Hit List
the next thing we know and it's like
these people are just trying to get
worse because they're doing great work
and it takes years for these things to
come out
so this cast I mean let's just go
through this Castle of Chaos because it
looks freaking great Catherine Hahn
Agatha Harkness Emma Caulfield Ford
returning to Sarah Proctor from One
Division so interesting to re-watch One
Division and see her show up because the
character Dottie seemed to be just a
regular Westview resident but her name
is Sarah and she's married to a guy
named Proctor Sarah Proctor in in during
the Salem Witch Trials was uh the
daughter of uh of Proctor who's like
like Prosecuting these things like so
there's a there's a Sarah Proctor in the
history of the Salem Witchcraft it's
very interesting I also remember when we
were watching the show through the first
time you know when that second episode
comes she acts so strangely and we all
thought that she was gonna maybe have a
bigger role or like turn be revealed to
be someone bigger so I love that the
seeds were probably there and probably
in an earlier version of this of of the
story but they're just carrying it
through to this like next spin-off show
which I I enjoy we also have uh Aubry
Plaza in this cast we don't know what
role probably a member of the coven we
don't really know yet very exciting for
Aubry Plaza to join the MCU she was in
another Marvel title Legion as uh as
Benny Lenny uh one of David holler's
Alters or one of his or what I think was
an incarnation of uh the Devil with the
yellow eyes unless someone was taken Joe
Locke who's gonna be playing a TV
character Ali on Maria dizzia uh sashir
zameda from Saturday Night Live
obviously playing a character and of
course Patti LuPone joining us cast
there's also speculation that Elizabeth
Olsen could come back as a Scarlet Witch
that's I mean that is our hope yeah yeah
that's that's like Miss Marvel right
like you're gonna have to we we need we
need a little uh a glimpse from the big
dog right we gotta see I think they
gotta get a little bit of Elizabeth
Olsen in this one hell yeah now I am
currently re-watching One Division for a
big project that I'm doing for the new
rock stars Network I'm not going to talk
about it yet you will all find out an
announcement that we are making on
January 2nd that's just for you who you
loyalists who joined us for inside
Marvel today the real no there's not too
many of you these days because it's not
a ton of Marvel news but you you brave
souls stuck around so you got that
little tidbit January 2nd
um but when I rewatched the one division
finale Wanda traps Agatha in her own
personal Westview hex as a nosy neighbor
character even when that hex Fades and
is gone presumably AG the Harkness is
still stuck on this Loop uh Agatha knows
what's coming and she begs Wanda not to
do this she even calls her cruel but
Wanda just smirks and she does it anyway
it's a really really dark moment very
Black Mirror of Wanda to do that but
Agatha's still wearing a brooch and then
in the next scene Agatha weirdly
disappears in the background it's weird
I beg of you re-watch this it does not
make sense how quick okay really
Catherine Hahn they just want to get her
opposite so she didn't have to sit in
the background and keep doing her
business but it's just weird the way
it's edited
um so two questions that I have for you
Brandon that I want to talk about with
that the
um
one
in the moment of her witch trial uh when
the other the rest of the members of the
coven were draining her powers do we
think Agatha had the dark hole at that
point and that's the Forbidden magic
that she was practicing and then two do
we think Agatha has a relationship with
Mephisto does she know Mephisto is she
like the Harley and quinzel to the Joker
um and that's the kind of relationship
they have this is a you know this is a
an argument I've had in the office many
times uh uh uh first part of your
question in that moment I do not believe
she has the dark hold for a couple
reasons one uh why would this this
Covenant of witches in Salem have the
dark hold for her to have right in
theory it's in Wonder Gore Mountain or
what we now know the dark cold is is a
copy of what's in Wonder core Mountain I
don't think these witches would have
that I think they're too small time
they're just doing their thing they
probably have a collection of dark magic
that she has started to experiment with
but I think her experiences with them
turning on her like that and her
draining their powers she this is going
to lead her to seek out the dark cold
because I don't think she has the dark
hold from like 1600s to you know 2024 or
whatever you know Post in game I don't
think she's holding on to the dark hole
for that long yeah she would have been
able to do way more yeah I think her her
Discovery the dark world has been a
recent phenomenon
um I think you're right I think if she
had the dark hold we would have seen her
with it in the past we would have seen
Eleanor holding it and snapping it shut
like this is not for you or would it
come out of her bag and bit all the
other witches uh like the monster book
from Harry Potter But to answer your
question about Mephisto that's I don't I
never considered that at that moment she
has a relationship but there could be a
Mephisto leading her toward she doesn't
know it's Mephisto you know leading her
towards discovering the dark hole or
something like that uh or leading her on
this journey of dark magic because he
sees in her her potential uh so that
that's an interesting idea that maybe
he's like somehow leading her down this
path she doesn't know it's because yet
but uh he he's playing a role in getting
her to where she needs to go yeah I mean
I I wonder if we might see you know the
the MCU loves flashing back to right
around the time the blip ended or
sometime during the blip just to shows
these little vignettes uh we saw when
Elena bolova undusted when Monica Rambo
and dusted we saw Bucky in wakanda uh
like having his campfire moment with the
door milage uh I wonder if we might see
a little flashback moment with Agatha
wherever she is as a witch gets visited
by Mephisto and he gives her the dark
hold he's the one who's able to like he
has it yeah whatever because his form
can appear anywhere across space right
right maybe he presents it to her and
says use this there's a woman I want you
to recruit steal her power you can do it
you know he's the one who sends her on
that Journey she has this kind of
alliance with him she's like captivated
by him a lot I got grilled you know
dragged across the coals rightfully I
would probably say for for predicting so
hard that Mephisto would show up in one
division but it's only just because
Agatha Harkness has that relationship
with Mephisto in the comics and they
were and granted a lot of Marvel TV
shows do not follow beat for beat but up
until that point they really were with
Agatha Harkness there was so much with
the way that character was like
volunteering to babysit the kids the way
the kids were called demon spawn I was
just really shocked I still remained
shocked at the people who producing that
show were like oh it never crossed our
mind to put Mephisto in this or even to
imply that he would be I don't know I
think in a pre you know in a universe
where covet didn't happen and there they
had stayed on the same release schedule
that they had planned I think there
there were probably early talks about it
because the skeletons are all there the
structure's there for Mephisto that's
why we thought so hard on it I think
they were like well maybe we're gonna do
it and then when things had to get moved
around they're like scrap that plan but
some lines of dialogue stayed behind and
they're like yeah just act like we're
never going to do Mephisto we'll get to
it later because they have been just
like kind of teasing it everywhere
especially even like door love and
thunder kind of establishing like you
know the carpenter character and like a
Satan character and we know early drafts
of that movie you know Russell Crowe was
even considered to be Satan so it's like
they're they're so close to doing this
now Satan in Memphis are very different
I realized that Mephisto is just
cosplaying as Satan but like they
they're so close to like doing that
character that I think early on they
wanted to do it but when plans change
that's the one thing about the MCU is
like if one movie changes like
everything changes if yeah when it comes
out changes or like who who the
characters are gonna be has like insane
Ripple effects so you can't dog yourself
too hard they were teasing it so heavily
and you know I I think a lot of people
say well want a vision didn't need
Mephisto right and my response to that
is it maybe didn't need if it's like a
red dude in a suit but it did need grief
like it was not Agatha all along alone
Agatha was in a partnership with Wanda's
own grief and grief is the real villain
of that series grief even victimizes
Agatha there is like it's a triangle of
uh of a relationship there a grief
triangle I would even argue because it's
not just Wanda versus Agatha it's Wanda
and it's one of being torn apart by both
Agatha and grief and grief is some other
kind of external force in that show that
Wanda is kind of blind to and Agatha is
blind she's asking Wanda how are you
doing this one it's like I don't know
right so if neither of them have the
answer there neither of them are lying
to each other it means that there is
someone who knows and that someone is
grief now grief is an abstract concept
but like we're learning more and more in
the MCU how various abstract Concepts
like love or actual sentient beings and
I think it's just a very easy math to do
just to say Mephisto is the source of
all green the universe that makes a lot
of sense yeah it it's a very astute
observation Eric because it is easy to
forget that in the beginning you know
it's kind of implied that Agatha showed
up because she senses this powerful dark
magic happen she's like oh I need to go
to this person is and see what I can
learn and what she realizes it's
essentially a child who has a weapon
they don't understand she wants to take
it away immediately she's like well I
should just take this over uh but yeah
it wasn't always her and I don't think
it was always her intent from the
beginning to just come in and steal the
powers of of Wanda but when she saw that
she was the foretold Scarlet Witch and
saw that she had no idea what she was
doing she was like well I have to take
these Powers away from you or else
you're going to destroy the world like
look what you've done look what you've
done here in my view the Jedi are bad is
what she said
you know in this project that I'm
working on I do make a case that like
Agatha is more of the protagonist of One
Division than Wanda is Wanda is the
focal character but Agatha based off of
the decision she makes is more of a hero
than Wanda is this is a tragedy where
the villain wins by the end of it when
when act when Wanda wins and like I
compare you know there's a moment where
uh Agatha has both Billy and Tommy by
those leashes and she's like choking
them it's hard to say that that person's
a hero but one of my favorite heroines
in all of film is Rippling and Aliens if
she torches and shoots baby eggs in
front of an alien xenomorph Queen you
can't tell me that that's any better or
any worse
protect us or hero in danger and
endangered children in a story if there
were a planet full of pigs they'd be
horrified to see what we're doing to
pigs on this planet when they showed up
they would be horrified
we are the monsters I Am Legend
yeah so I I think 2023 will be the year
of me Fisto I think he might show up
just in a scene or two for uh ironheart
and I think he's going to have a pretty
important role in Coven of chaos I love
it I don't think he's ever going to I
don't need to there to ever be a mepisto
show in the MCU but I would just like if
he's just kind of this background
character who comes to talk to people
from time to time yeah he's like the cue
in uh Star Trek it just shows up to
create some mischief and then now I'm
gonna go deal something else now I'll be
back in uh next season yeah or from the
animorphous mythology the element no
that one this just appears to Tobias
sometimes it says you're gonna be an
athlete now
there's there's like five people who
watch this video who are like yes yes
going crazy they're animorphing as we
speak all right let's uh oh actually
there's a
dying to have about
in there we're going to close out 2023
with
um but before we continue we want to
thank Helix sleep for sponsoring this
episode one way to make 2023 the best
year yet is to get some more sleep and
here at new rockstars We Trust Helix to
protect our sleep with the best
mattresses in the world I have a helix
mattress Mt recently producer Zach
producer John we all got some Helix
mattresses here Helix sleep has a quiz
that takes just two minutes to complete
it matches your body type and your sleep
preferences to the perfect matches for
you everybody is unique Helix knows that
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium and burn mattresses mattress is
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot matches are great for spinal
alignment to prevent morning aches and
pains even a helix plus mattress or plus
size sleepers producer Zach took the
Helix quiz and was matched with the
midnight Luxe mattress because he's a
side sleeper that needed a softer
mattresses and now he doesn't wake up
with a sore shoulder or neck like he did
with the other mattresses so just go to
helixsleep.com inside marble take their
two-minute sleep quiz and they'll match
you to a customized mattress they'll
give you the best sleep of your life
they have a 10 year warranty and you get
to try it out for 100 nights risk-free
Helix is offering up to 200 dollars off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners at Helix sleep.com
slash inside marble okay uh so some of
our uh episodes at the end of the year
for inside Marvel Brandon have been our
rankings of Marvel phase four we rank
for Marvel phase four series on Disney
plus and then we rank the Marvel phase
four movies and one thing that came up
is this question of which of these two
categories have been better in phase
four and I want to ask you uh think
about like your favorite phase four
movies think about your favorite phase
four series and then think of your least
favorite phase four movies and your
least favorite phase 4 Series which do
you think has been better marble TV on
Disney Plus or Marvel movies ah I will
say I think
I think the movies overall have been
better than the series but I think the
the series the best series have been
better than the best movies does that
make sense yeah and I think I agree with
you on that I think you can't deny like
what Juan Division I mean one division
as their first show was incredible uh
just just stunning really well done so
weird to remember like those first three
weeks when we're like what is going on
this is the weirdest thing I've ever
seen uh and then like Loki really really
killed it I mean look it was just
incredible too but and those were so
great and I think really surprised a lot
of people some of the series not so
great uh you know I I accept the
arguments they feel like long movies
that were chopped up in each episode on
its on its own doesn't feel well but
like I was so surprised by something
like Miss Marvel which I thought was
like so fun and energetic and different
uh and like really tried something that
I I really liked and I got into and I
love the like directing in that
uh or on that show I thought it was they
did some fun stuff there yeah I think I
would just say I I totally agree with
you that the best Marvel Disney Plus
shows have been better than the because
my favorite movies were like no way home
right versus Madison and and black
panther were kind of forever those are
my top three uh my top three Marvel uh
Disney Plus shows were Loki One Division
and I can't remember what I put in my
number three it might have been Miss
Marvel yeah I think it was mismo
um and I put those three especially
those top two above the top two movies
of phase four and I think Brandon I
think I would even say that okay so the
bottom of my phase four TV shows were
the Falcon the Winter Soldier and
She-Hulk I think yeah and I think I
still liked those better than Black
Widow and eternals yeah yeah I I agree
with those sentiments I mean it's hard
because there's more to criticize in
like six episodes of the show but like
at least the Falcon Winter Soldier had
that uh Sam Wilson storyline with Carl
lumley's character you know like that I
think was so interesting it had some
really high highs uh on that show yeah
um it just also had some like a really
really bad ending it did it well they
had to change so much but I mean like
that show gave us you know John Walker
like
concaving a dude skull and the street
was like a pretty intense moment and
like yeah all the Carl lonely stuff it's
like give me more of that show like show
me a flashback of Bucky fighting him
like come on do me do me that favor and
then with like She-Hulk it felt like the
way they arranged the episodes felt a
little weird and I almost wanted more
lawyer show I I don't know it was like I
wish they had just gotten Daredevil all
the way earlier instead of waiting so
long because we knew about it it was
just like it kind of kind of ruined the
momentum for the rest of the show I
thought but yeah I I hear your points on
the movies too and like yeah I love
Spider-Man uh no way home but does that
movie exist without all the other ones I
don't know like if you just walk in and
watch is that a good movie on its own I
don't know right uh yeah kind of the
same way I feel about like Avatar is it
a good movie on its own I don't know but
like you go in and watch it and it's
incredible right yeah I think no way
home is still a good movie on its own
because I a lot of people aren't really
don't really dig the college stuff or
like the college entry stuff I do I like
all that stuff and no way home I think
it was really really well done and not
shown yet in the MCU people were like oh
that's so typical I've seen that before
I'm like not in the to you we've never
seen a coming-of-age story of like a kid
trying to get to college and then like
he feels bad for like right ruining his
two friends lives so he goes to a wizard
to Gaslight everyone over Society just
ignore that ignore that that's Peter
Parker or Spider-Man imagine there's
just a story about a kid who goes to
like uh his local wizard to uh erase the
memories of society sure because of some
crime he got implicated in some like War
crime and he ruined his friend's lives
like that that's still a movie I would
go watch yeah I mean it's like the liar
liar or something like that where it's
like one person has this huge effect on
the world because of something that's
just happening to them and they don't
know how to explain yeah they're just
trying to do the right thing yeah I
think it was also people were like oh
well they just brought back people I'm
like but it wasn't random the way they
they were able to get this interesting
like pseudo Refugee plot of forgiving
these Multiverse men for the crimes they
committed in their home world yeah and
like Aunt May being like no they need
they deserve a second chance and then
seeing that play out like Peter having
his own second chance that he gives
himself by like allowing himself to give
someone else a second chance like I
thought they it was hard to like fix all
these things and to make Toby McGuire
and Andrew Garfield's eras feel great
and worthy it felt made him feel less
random like random mistakes and more
like no it was an inevitable step in
their stories that led to this well yeah
and it it does like put a nice story
through line in what our what did exist
as like capitalist decisions to make
profit for a company right instead it
was like no we can make this feel good
narratively and like really pay off for
the fans which was great and like
something really awesome yeah and I
thought I I did appreciate that in phase
for uh of the MCU there was just a lot
of attempts at new things they tried
some different stuff yeah like I was
really impressed with like shanxi like
that was so different than like a lot of
the other movies uh you know by the
third act yeah it's like the big third
act battle blah blah blah but like
having those martial arts sequences were
so different and like it felt great I
was really impressed by like that movie
like trying something new yeah I agree I
agree in general there's a lot of
experimentation in this phase I just
think at the end of the day Loki and
Wanda Vision I I really enjoyed more
than than all the movies yeah they were
really good they were so good now yeah
there's been a lot of like mid uh MCU
Marvel Disney Plus shows they just had a
lot of mid episodes that kind of sink
all those yeah so I think a lot of
people are suicide but for people who
look at the goodness and things they
think they look at the goodness from the
Disney Plus shows outshines I mean we
also got to consider the the specials I
think werewolf by night was incredible
just nothing like a Guardians holiday
special yeah I know Zach didn't like the
Guardians holiday special but I liked it
it was different it was good but yeah I
mean werewolf by night was simply uh
just so good and so many people
immediately were like do more of this
give me just like a little one hour
thing like that's what I want like that
that was fun and just really it knew
what it its mission was and it
accomplished its Mission and it wasn't
tied to like this needs to tie into to
all this other stuff it was like no
here's a good little story we can give
you and you can watch it whenever you
want it's great I think a lot of people
felt that MCU phase four was a bit
oversaturated I disagree with that
premise I'm like you know as long as you
uh have like give these showrunners and
directors the resources they need to
tell the story they want to tell but I
wonder do you think that the MCU would
be better in Phase five I know they're
not going to do this because they've
already announced release dates for all
these things but just hypothetically do
you think the MCU would be better if
every year we only got two movies two
series and then two holiday specials
that 2-2-2 approach I think that would
be enough for to sustain everyone it
wouldn't be enough to sustain and I
think they would feel pressured to focus
on the bigger characters you know I
think okay than three three three and
three three movies three series three
specials I think the specials are just
like an underutilized asset by the
studio you could tell so much story and
introduced characters so much better in
a special than you can in a six episode
series sometime and I hope they see that
and I hope that leaned that way I mean
like financially I'm sure they'll see
like well that'll cost us way less money
you know if we can do that and I'm I'm
hoping they do that yeah because I I
what I really hope too is that they let
you know some of these creators have the
control to make more stylistic things uh
unless like it needs to fit into the
cookie cutter mold I I would love to see
that more you know in Star Wars we saw
with like Andor right like this was a
true like Vision that is like written
overseen by from the writing and the
design and the direction like love all
that like uh and I think they really
accomplish that with like Loki and Wanda
vision and some of the other shows felt
like it was like a mishmash right so
what these creators have more rain over
the show and like really really execute
the Visions they have and I think that
will help yeah I think when you do a
series there's like a pressure to have a
b plot and a c plot and as a rewatch One
Division and I think the one part of it
that doesn't really hold up is
everything that happens outside of
Westview all the stuff in the sword Camp
nothing against I think Jimmy woo Darcy
Monica Rambo they're all perfectly fun
to watch it's just like hayward's not
that compelling of a villain and like
there's just a lot of scenes that feel
like this is just like a not that great
episode of Agents of Shield this is like
characters wearing jackets in like a
gray and blue toned lab military lab
sites and they're kind of like we're
being detained right now here the beat
and punch them and flip them over and
now we're gonna wear their uniforms and
sneak around it's just like
no thanks not interested
um so what I like about specials is like
you don't need to do any of that you
just tell one character story for 60
minutes and then we're done I would love
to see more of that in 2023 let's do it
we can do it MCU I think so I think I
don't need more than three MCU movies in
a year
um I mean look we at new rock stars
certainly love it because we have more
as a fan as a fan I think you could
totally sustain fans attention with just
like uh quality over quantity and as
long as you have like a couple big
releases a year like fans will stay with
you yeah like we're not talking about
going year like we I think there was uh
two years between uh the summer of 2008
where we had uh Iron Man and Hulk there
was nothing in 2009 and then in 2010 we
had Iron Man 2. so there you go we can
do it we can do it all right well what a
year it's been a new rock stars uh let's
talk about all this stuff a beautiful
Year we're gonna have uh if it's not
already on the channel I don't know what
day it is today I think this weekend
we're gonna have our annual what we got
wrong episode uh it's and we did
something real different with this one
we got all the new rockstars hosts
involved because all of our hosts has
been making some [ __ ] Series this
year and it's fun we had a lot of fun
with the time we had a great time
filming that video I can't wait to see
it on my channel yeah I can't wait for
all of you to see it as well
um so be sure to keep an eye out for
that I believe it's going to come out
um December 31st the final day of the
year New Year's Eve uh and then yeah
January 2nd
mark your calendars big announcements
big announcements big announcements uh
but we'll leave it there for this
episode of inside Marvel
um you can follow me at EA Vos follow
Brandon at grin and Barrick and you can
subscribe to inside Marvel wherever I
bring your podcast thank you for joining
us this year in 2022 and we'll see you
in 2023. bye everybody see you next year
bye-bye
foreign